serena williams the a pro football talk
just because I need to get what's going
on in a Dallas Cowboys country but
before that I I do have to say
congratulations Sheree and I haven't had
a chance to talk with you but
congratulations on the Hall of Fame
induction and the award given to you the
dick McConnell war for the reporting of
a professional NFL team for as long as
you have so first of all congratulations
on that well thanks I appreciate that
and now to the tough questions you ready
here what is Jason what what is he
thinking coming back obviously he was
away for a year but to come back now to
this Cowboys team and to seem like Jerry
Jones said he's saying he knew this was
in the mix for the last couple weeks
kind of what ignited this flame for
Jason Witten well you know I think
things didn't work out exactly as
planned with the ESPN so I'm sure that
was part of his thinking and then I
think mostly he dismissed the game miss
playing football and and somebody's
going to pay you three and a half
million and up to five million to play
twenty five snaps the game to play the
game that you love and do what you love
to do why not why not go try it again so
they're gonna find out what kind of
shape he's in I talked to all the
Cowboys officials here in Indy last
night and they'll find out what kind of
shape he's in as the spring goes on he
obviously hasn't played in a year hasn't
been in football shape hasn't kept in
football shape you just can't do that
doing other things and and so it's gonna
take him a while to get up to speed and
of course he knows the playbook and all
those sorts of things but I just getting
back into game shape and in football
shape will be the biggest thing for him
this spring and they'll assess where he
is and see if he can help the biggest
thing may be him helping in the locker
room from a leadership standpoint yeah
was Shireen last year with a this
question was posed to Jason it was you
know I'm I'm not a cowboy anymore I'm
now and you know I'm in broadcasting no
I won't be coming back he kind of shut
that door and then all of a sudden that
door opened again was this possibly
talked with Jason Garrett you know this
offseason about possibly returning I'm
just trying to figure out from
Cowboys perspective on why they would
bring Jason wid back who'll be 37 years
old I think if he takes a snap teasing
well you know I do think the leadership
plays a big part in that a big role in
that and you know they thought Daken and
Zeke did a pretty good job in the
leadership role last season but they
haven't played as long as Jason Witten
has played they have Shawn Lee on the
other side of this football and they
want to reduce his contract and bring
him back for the same reason and both of
those guys likely won't be starters
digest Jason could be a starter but
playing 25 snaps you're certainly not a
full-time starter in this league when
you only play that percentage of the
snap so she's probably gonna be
somewhere like Antonio Gates 36 percent
something like that of the snaps but
from a leadership standpoint and you
know they weren't that great at the
tight end position either and so I think
he they think he can help those young
tight ends like Darwin came on obviously
in that greater season finale against
Philadelphia and played great but you
know that was one game they need him to
do it on a consistent basis over the
long term and also in suitcases to help
those young Thai dance develop you can
reach her at NFL Sherine on Twitter
Serena Williams or Pro Football Talk and
hall-of-famer I like to throw that out
there but Sheree I need to figure this
out could this signing and this is my
theory right here sure you ready for it
could this signing of Jason Witten or
coming out of retirement could this have
anything to do with the new offensive
coordinator Kellen Moore who will be you
know basically putting his stamp on this
offense no longer Scott Linehan near but
could people look at this signing as
maybe another leader in the clubhouse
for this team to lean on to get this
offensive coordinator and tell him or
another guy that he can kind of lean on
to get everything out to the players
yeah I think that's probably a part of
it too and I'll say this you know
they're probably gonna lose Cole Beasley
who was kind of a safety net underneath
on third down and and so Jason can be
that guy possibly and take some of those
snaps that Cole Beasley would have taken
last year and he's not going to be
around anymore I mean they'd like
keeping but you can't keep everybody the
free agents probably gonna get more
money elsewhere and they'll work Allen
Hurns in there but I think they still
trust probably Witten more than they
trust Hearns to go get open on some of
the short route routes on third down and
so I you know I think that's a big part
of it too but you're right it's he's
played with Kellan he knows Kellan can
relay Callens message in the locker room
and and I think that's important and and
help those guys figure out what count
wants so yeah I do think that's big part
of it now say this too I don't think
that them signing Jason Witten roshani
Jason Witten will preclude them from
drafting and tied in I think it's still
possible that they could drop it to a
young tight end and again it would be
great for women to be able to develop
those guys
well Shireen that's the business of the
Dallas Cowboys as well when I say
business they've got to make some
decisions or some contract extensions
some possible tags obviously I'll start
here on the defensive side because we
know DeMarcus Lawrence they got about
what about four or five days to possibly
have another designation of the
franchise tag how do you see this
playing out with DeMarcus Lawrence again
possibly being on the franchise tag in a
couple of days they have to make that
designation yeah a Tuesday afternoon is
the date and they want to try to get
something done and they haven't given up
on getting that done now yeah well it's
obvious we're running out of time to see
a deal done but they gave me my first
proposal they're going to meet again
later today face to face and and hope
they hopefully they can bang something
out over the next two or three days here
in Indy and get something worked out so
you don't have to use the franchise tag
if not they'll use the franchise tag to
to buy them time to get a long-term deal
done but the goal for both sides is
long-term deal it's not use the
franchise I guess to get a long-term
deal done with him they believe they can
do that I think it's going to be
somewhere in the range if you figure
with the tag pay him and and all that
take all that into consideration
somewhere in the range of 20 million a
year which is you know it's going to
make him the highest paid for three
defensive end in football which I think
he's earned that then you got three
other names too
and it goes I guess falls in line of the
pecking order of the Dallas Cowboys
because dak Prescott eligible for a
contract extension Ezekiel Elliott
eligible for a contract extension oh and
the guy that you gave up a first-round
pick for in this year's draft Amari
Cooper also eligible for a contract
extension
who gets the extension first in your
opinion of the three well you have
Bayern Jones and these are your options
right and all for those guys that that
you did well and if you can throw
DeMarcus Lawrence in there those so
those five guys at their positions are
going to be them among the highest paid
players when it's all said that among
the highest paid players at their
position in the NFL so they're gonna
have a lot of money going out here over
the short term this is you know all
these they're not under pressure to do
them because with dak and Zeke to have
them under contract obviously for a
little bit longer with this year's
options and franchise tags and all that
they could use but they want to get them
done they want to reward the players
they feel like they've done a good job
and have Bright Futures for the Cowboys
Dax is going to be complicated but I
would think that would be the one they
would focus on trying to get done second
I think Byron Jones is probably if you
just look at the timing of it you know
fit your option they need to get his
done obviously before the years out so
they don't go into next year having to
use the franchise tag on him I think
he's probably the most pressing but I
think they would like to get back
Prescott's done first and then the
others kind of fall in line but I'm sure
they're working on all all four of those
who all five of those count DeMarcus
Lawrence who will be done first
hopefully but working on all of those at
the same time but it you know they're
all complicated but I would say Dax's
the most complicated to get done and one
I know that they would like to see done
before the season starts at Pro Football
Talk Serena Williams joining the Rich
Eisen show Kirk Morrison filling in for
Rich and you've mentioned in a couple
times that the the delicate complicated
process of signing deck Prescott what
makes it so difficult what makes that
signing is it the number of years is it
how they truly feel about him or
is it with the numbers of what the
starting quarterbacks are making in
today's NFL does he fall in line with
some of those numbers that we seem to
think are you know already pretty
outrageous yeah and I think that's
exactly it I think that's when you when
you look at it and what he's done it's
like where does he fit into that because
you do have some quarterbacks up there
who you think ok he's probably better
than they are but then you know you he
hasn't done as much as Aaron Rodgers you
know he had Tom Brady of course had
given the Patriots a discount which has
been very underappreciated probably
outside of the Patriots organization for
what he's given to that club to allow
them to do things with a sour cap
because the salary is so low so I don't
know that you compare him to him and dak
has said that but yeah just where does
he fit into that how much has he done
what kind of future does he have what
kind of quarterback is he truly going to
be and and how much is he worth and you
know as you pointed out I mean the going
rate quarterback of the market is
probably going to pay him more than then
people are gonna think I think it's
going to be toward 30 million I don't
know get over 30 million but I think
it's going to be upwards of 20 million
toward thirty million at least when that
thing's done with a lot of guaranteed
money and that's just what the market is
and what it pays and it's certainly
going to affect cowboyed salary cap
they've been in such good shape over the
last couple of years with not having to
pay a quarterback that big money and now
they're getting their pay as I said all
five of these guys are going to be among
the highest paid players at their
positions when it's all said and done
over the next however many months it's
going to take to get all these bills
done and and that's just going to take a
you know big piece out of your salary
cap and they're gonna have to go cheap
on some other things yeah but we talk
about the players so much and you
mentioned those five guys who I've got
circled here but we all love job
security right Shareen I think that's
yeah no matter what profession you're in
so when I look at the head coach and
Jason Garrett who does not have an
extension on the table who's going into
the last year of his contract
how are people in Dallas looking at this
year for Jason gear is there a number or
in terms of
Wynn's is there a place whether they get
to the Super Bowl a conference
championship what would be I would say
the right amount of success for him to
keep his job after this season
yeah and it's a great question and I
think it is taking that next step and
that next step obviously get to a
championship game and something they
haven't done since 1995 which was their
last Super Bowl season and there's very
few teams I think Washington Detroit are
the only two teams that have gone that
long or longer with this well get into a
championship game in any NFC and and so
they certainly would hope to do that
think they have the team to do that or
building the team to do that but I do
think he has to take that next step I
don't think he can do what he did in
2014 when he was a so to speak lame-duck
coach and when in the last year of his
contract and they won the division and
they lost in the divisional round to
Green Bay on the Dez Bryant catch no
catch game I think you got to do more
than that I think he has to take that
next step to keep his job yeah I know
it's always one of the difficult things
of a player going into a year in which a
coach may not be there the following
year so when I look at this draft for
the Cowboys which they don't have a
first-round pick because of the RA
Cooper deal what do they do in the
giraffe you betcha we talked we talked
about the players so they've got a sign
or figure out what they're gonna do for
the future but how do you even look at a
Cowboys giraffe right now what's the
glaring need that they can possibly
draft up coming from in 2019 draft well
I think the very first thing you look at
and they would tell you the same thing
because of ask the same question this
week is the offensive line and that's
because of David Irving there let him
walk away obviously the problems he's
had now facing another suspension and
then the suspicion of her in the Gregory
now they hope Gregor comes back and
there's a chance he comes back he's
suspended indefinitely so they're hoping
he comes back but you can't count right
this is when you're suspended
indefinitely there's no timetable there
you don't know when he's going to be
back so they've got a plan for for not
having him and if they do it's going to
be a bonus but I think they have to get
better the defense's in the defensive
line they have the draft defensive
linemen and then
and obviously I think an upgraded safety
is needed they are not going to go after
Earl Thomas he wants too much money
unless he would come down and what he
wants it doesn't get the offer he thinks
he's going to get but I think everybody
expects him to become the highest-paid
safety in football somebody to pay him
that and it's not going to be Dallas so
if he gets the offer that that he thinks
she's going to get and he's going to go
elsewhere and that creates to me a need
for them at at the safety position in
the draft and I'd also think you'd look
at that like I said tight in I don't
think what's return precludes that it
does help them in that they don't have
to that's not a just a pressing need but
I think they would look that direction
and backup running back is an obvious
one they need to and a guy like treyvion
Williams from Texas A&M maybe somebody
you get lighter that could help you as
the backup running back well as you say
treyvion Williams I do have a another TV
on here in the studio that I can't wait
for him to run the 40 so I will keep my
entree fee on Williams as well but
Shireen thank you for the time always a
pleasure to have you on and there's
never a dull moment in Dallas right no
there's not
thank you for having me all right thank
you that's Serena Williams you can
follow her on Twitter at NFL Serena
pro-football talk
covering the NFL for 24 seasons the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience